So we will have a running example of, how that the muscles [UNKNOWN] work so
that whenever we do something, kind of, to explain it, we
will also show how it works. So, this is an example of how the issue is working.
First, this is going to be our issue Q. I'm showing four instructions here.
This is the first instruction. This is the second one, third one and so on.
So, we will issue in program order which means the first instruction that we're
going to be issue is going to be this F2 equals F4 plus F1.
This is really an add but I'm writing it this way because it's more compact.
Next, for each of the faulting point registers which we're going to name F1,
F2, F3 and F4. There is a register alias table, or
RAT where we're going to keep which instructions supposed to produce that
register. If there is nothing here, that actually points to the register file,
so pretty much if there is nothing here in F1, that's going to mean that you
can just find the value for F1 in the actual F1 in the register file.
This is a register file we have four registers and this is their actual values.
When we go through the example we will actually compute with them.
So again this is the register file. Again the RAT when it's empty says that
basically this means F1 can just be that from the register file. You don't have
wait for it. And finally we are going to have our reservation stations.
We going to name them RS1, 2, 3 for the other reservation stations and 4 and
5 for the multiplication reservation station. So we really have 5 reservation
stations, but note that you can use only these three for adds and only three for
multiply and divides. Now we are ready to actually issue an instruction so
again this is going to be the first one we issue. The first step is to
take it from the instruction buffer. The next step is to look at the RAT and
find whether our inputs are ready or not. And in this case,
both of the inputs are ready. F1 and F4 are both available. So
we're going to say that this is. And add and we are going to take the value for,
in this case, F4 and F1, and that is going to be 0.71 and
it is going to be 3.14, and place the instruction in the reservation station,
of course that assumes that there is a reservation station available, we
will see eventually, what happens when there isn't any. And the final step for
register renaming is to say that the result of the instruction F2 is going to
come from now on, from reservation station 1. So here, we will write, RS1.
So future instructions that want F2 are not going to read minus 1.
There going to wait for this result to be produced.
So this is the reining in of the very first instruction. One final step that we
will do of course is remove this instruction from the issue queue and
what's going to happen now is this is going to shift down but for
my example that's going to be very difficult to do so
I'm just going to kind of cross out this instruction. So this is,
this just means that you know, this instruction has been removed from the issue
queue. To make things more interesting for the remaining instructions and
also to see what happens when an instruction is renamed, let's issue one or
two more instructions. So let's issue the next instruction, which is this one.
This is a divide. We need to find the free reservation station here,
say it's a divide. F2 and F3 are going to be the parameters for
this instruction. F2 comes from RS1 so we cannot simply read this value here.
We're going to say here that RS1 is what we are waiting for
but F3 is available so we're going to get 2.72 from the registry file,
and we now mark this instruction as,
we're going to basically take it out of the issue queue and this is so
very easy to forget but when we do that. We need to mark that the result,
the F1 is from now on not going to be coming from here. It's going to be coming
from reservation station 4. And we're going to issue this instruction too.
It's a subtraction so it's going to go here. F1 and F2 are the parameters,
we see that neither of those two can be read from the register files, so
what we'll going to do is were going to mark here that that,
that the first parameter is going to be produced by RS4, the second one is
going to be produced by RS1, we'll going to then mark it. F4 is coming
from RS2,. And we're going to remove this instruction from the issue queue.
Of course, more instructions are probably going to come this way, but we're
not going to look at that. Because again, that, that too many instructions for
this example. Now let's say that there wasn't an issue slot here. We then.
Couldn't issue the next instruction in the next cycle, until we are actually
done executing one, one of these two. I'm not going to do that but just,
just keep in mind that when you want to issue an instruction you first have to
check whether reservation station is available. If not then we simply cannot
issue that instruction. Let's issue it now because we do have room for it.
It's an addition. Of F2 and F3. F2 comes from reservation station 1.
F3 comes from the register file. So we're just going to take the 2.72.
We're going to then rename F1 to point to this result. And
now we see that F1 is already renamed to reservation station 4.
That's basically, if you want to use F1, since this instruction,
you would be waiting for it's result, but now F1 is being basically renamed to
another reservation station, so this is how registering and
naming here works in Tomasulo's algorithm, so what we are going to do is we
are going to basically override this. With the name of this reservation station,
which is RS3. And now we have issued all of our four instructions.
In a real processor you would issue one instruction each cycle.
And probably some of these instructions would have executed by the time we
issue all of them but I just wanted to show you how issue works if,
for example, nothing could execute for some reason. Now that we
have gone through an example of issuing, let's see what the next step is